let's jump to the story from Insider and
get into the into the meat potatoes here
this PayPal story Insider reports PayPal
Falls after weekend blowback over
misinformation policy that would find
users twenty five hundred dollars the
stock fell six percent on Monday
following the company's botched
acceptable use policy update the company
faced backlash after its updated policy
included a fine of twenty five hundred
dollars for a variety of things but it
included hate speech against
marginalized groups and spreading
misinformation and it said at PayPal's
sole discretion to determine meaning
they could just be alike you said the
sky was blue I disagree yoink give me
your money so this resulted in uh PayPal
coming out being like no no it was in
arrows and errors a mistake so the first
thing I want to say
because it affects us several months ago
we took PayPal off timcast.com and we
knew something like this was coming
we've we've seen too much ESG in banking
institutions too much censorship we knew
it was a huge vulnerability